foreign
marketing is a strategic method that
utilizes digital channels to promote
products or Services it involves
activities like social media marketing
SEO content marketing and email
marketing to engage with a specific
online audience the objective is to
increase brand visibility attract
customers and generate leads and improve
conversions by leveraging digital
platforms and data driven insights
businesses can optimize their marketing
strategies personalized communication
and measure campaign performance in
today's competitive online landscape
digital marketing provides a cost
effective and trackable approach to
connect with customers and drive
business growth these days digital
marketing is one of the most trending
jobs digital marketing jobs are trending
due to Growing online presence cost
Effectiveness targeted marketing
measurable results constant Innovation
and Global reach this has increased the
demand of digital marketing
Professionals in the industry it is
predicted to have approximately 8 lakh
60 000 job openings in 2023 from apparel
industry to it fintech and Pharma
digital marketers are in huge demand the
salaries of digital marketer May differ
depending upon the skills location or
the company however on an average the
salary of digital marketing manager in
India is 6.4 lakhs per annum rupees
whereas in U.S it is 122 000 per annum
so hey everyone if you are looking to
try your hands on in this field then
here we have a magic course that will
help you to gain excellence in this
domain and grab highest paying jobs
under digital marketing presenting you
post graduate program in digital
marketing by simply learn a few key
features of this course includes master
classes delivered by audio faculty
Harvard Business publishing cases build
your website and learn real world
Hands-On written marketing techniques
Master sessions by meta blueprint
trainer six credit transfer for the
Purdue online Ms in communication
program meta certified digital marketing
associate exam voucher Worth Dollar
ninety nine five Capstone problem
statement and 15 plus course and
projects 10 plus case studies from the
brands like Adidas KFC Nike Intel Etc 35
Plus digital marketing tools and much
more with post graduate program and
digital marketing you will be skilled in
website creation behavioral marketing
keyword research search engine
optimization search engine marketing
campaign management social media
marketing mobile marketing content
marketing content strategy strategies
for paid campaigns analytics Roi and
evaluation AI Automation and emerging
technology by end of this course you
will gain expertise in the tools like
essay ranking chat GPT Google ads Google
analytics rf's MailChimp semrush used
SEO WordPress and much more so what I
find the course Link in the description
box so before we begin with the digital
marketing roadmap consider subscribing
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so without any further Ado let's begin
with digital marketing roadmap for 2023
in the dynamic world of digital
marketing a marketing roadmap is crucial
for businesses to navigate successfully
towards the growth by defining goals
understanding target audience and
implementing effective strategies
companies can establish a strong online
presence and Achieve marketing
objectives so here are the basic steps
if you are looking to become a
successful digital marketer let's begin
with step number one establish a solid
foundation learn marketing principles
and strategies be good with
communication and writing skills develop
analytical skills analyze data to drive
in sites understand consumer behavior
and market trends the next step we have
is to gain expertise in SEO and PPC
campaign SEO or search engine
optimization Master keyword research and
on-page optimization techniques as this
is the base of any digital marketing
efforts understand link building and
backlink Analysis with this it is also
necessary to have good understanding of
technical SEO including website speed
optimization and site structure stay up
to date with search engine algorithm
changes next is pay-per-click
advertising or PPC learn to create and
manage PPC campaigns on the platforms
like Google ads and Bing ads develop
skills and keyword bidding and targeting
and AD copywriting keep an eye on the
campaign performance and optimize for
better results explore remarketing and
display advertising moving ahead we need
to understand how to Leverage The Power
of social media and marketing gain
Proficiency in major social media
platforms like Facebook Instagram
Twitter and Linkedin understand social
media advertising and audience targeting
create engaging content and manage
social media communities analyze social
media metrics and utilize management
tools moving ahead content marketing and
email marketing are the powerful
techniques to gain more leads here
talking about content marketing develop
content creation skills like content
writing graphic designing and video
production learn content distribution
strategies like guest blogging and
influencer Outreach use analytics and
measurement tools to evaluate content
marketing Effectiveness moving towards
email marketing learn to build effective
email marketing campaigns understand
email Automation and segmentation
utilize email marketing platforms and
tools comply with email marketing
regulations and best practices with all
the above practices it is necessary to
have knowledge of web development
acquire higher knowledge of HTML CSS and
JavaScript get detailed understanding of
content Management systems or CMS like
WordPress UI ux design and more data can
provide valuable Insight in the business
growth gain expertise and data analysis
learn tools like Google analytics and
Google tag manager analyze website
traffic user behavior and conversion
rate and
a b testing which will help you to
understand what works better for
you an enhanced campaign performance
last but not the least stay updated
updated with industry news Trends and
best practices attend webinars
conferences and workshops engage with
online communities and participate in
discussions get certified in Google ads
Google analytics HubSpot or Facebook
blueprint well to bring it to your
notice the postgraduate program in
digital marketing covers all the
requirements as we discussed in this
video check the complete course details
from the course Link in the description
box so here we end up the digital
marketing roadmap we wish you a great
career as our Learners have from the
post graduate program in digital
marketing by simply learn listen to this
stories and their own words restarting
your career in a new country that too in
a new sector after a career break is
anything but hi my name is and I am a
digital marketer by profession I already
had experience in sales and public
relations so I wanted to learn digital
marketing so I opted a professional
certification program in digital
marketing from Purdue University offered
by simply learn on the basis of my past
experience and on my newly developed
skill I landed my first freelance
project with a company called country
air the best part about this job is it
is remote I can stay at home I can be
with my kids and I can also focus on my
hobbies too we have reached to the end
of this video If you like this video
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to stay tuned with
simply learn do like the video and share
it with your friends friends keep
watching keep learning and thanks for
watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here